they've got a new show coming out maybe
it's a show maybe it's a movie i don't
even know the difference anymore this is
on hbo
and it's it's a movie it's like a gal
pal
comedy about these gals
driving across the nation to to
kill a child this is called unpregnant
take a listen to the trailer there's a
woman
clearly taking a pregnancy test
she's pregnant oh that's so so terrible
is there anything worse than being
pregnant
oh having to have children oh woman
needs a procedure
is that possible by the way she's
looking up an abortion procedure for
women under 18. the law won't let me get
one without my parents knowing
[Music]
i know we're not close anymore true and
i'm the last person that you want to
help accurate
but i need your help and i don't have
anywhere else to go go where
to get the thing the procedure so you're
hiding this from your man
your best friend hey girl and your jesus
freak parents
and you thought why not ask bailey
butler to drive me hundreds of miles
cause she probably doesn't have anything
to do anyway
kind of yes bailey bailey come on
i'm just messing with you you're right i
do not have anything going on
hello if you don't help us out we're
going to be in so much trouble
well they find a nice lovely abortionist
to uh
kill this this gal's child without her
parents knowing
it's my life it's my choice and the
boyfriend says you know
i don't think that's what you want she
says uh that's not your choice
sorry buster it's your kid but it's not
your choice it's my my body
my choice to kill something that's not
my body a minor
going on a quest to kill her child
at the protestation of her jesus freak
parents
see they're jesus freaks if you think
that you shouldn't
kill children or if you think that even
if you should be able to kill children
but just like maybe children shouldn't
be able to kill children
that makes you a jesus freak but if you
support this culture
well you're not a freak you're totally
normal it's totally it's great
it's fabu i'm so glad that they were
able to drive across the country and
find that kindly abortionist
to snuff out a life
this is not an accident this didn't
happen by accident
this was planned out and encouraged
by the radical left it's gone back at
least until the 1960s it's actually gone
back earlier than that
radical leftists have always looked at
sex as a way
to transform society because sex is so
fundamental to who we are
that if you can transform the way that
we view sex you can crash social mores
break
traditional institutions transform the
way we even interact with the world and
and most importantly of all
you can break down people's constraints
on their own passions and
when people are all passion all emotion
all appetite they're much easier
to guide they're much easier to control
that's the political operation of the
sexual revolution that exploded in the
1960s since that time women have become
less happy according to a number of
studies both in relative terms to men
and in absolute terms that's a political
operation that's it
that's a genuine conspiracy you can read
all of the writings actually bernie
sanders very
famously during the primary it came out
that he had written on this this very
topic in the 60s and 70s the left was
very honest about the way they wanted to
harness sex for a political revolution
including a man who ran for president
just this year now they're a little less
honest about it they want to pretend
it's all just about liberation it's all
just about
about taking control of your body but of
course it's the opposite
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts